proverbs 30 verse 5.
every word of God proves true
he is a shield to those who take refuge
in him do not add to his words lest he
rebuke you and you be found a liar
Proverbs 16 verse 17.
the highway of the upright turns aside
from evil whoever guards his way
preserves his life
Pride goes before destruction and a
heart is spirit before a fall
Proverbs 17 verse 17.
a friend loves at all times and a
brother is born for adversity
Proverbs 15 15.
all the days of The Afflicted are evil
but the cheerful of heart has a
continual Feast better is a little with
the fear of the Lord than great treasure
and trouble with it
better is dinner of herbs where love is
than a fattened ox and hatred with it
[Music]
proverbs 31 verse 10.
excellent wife who can find
she is far more precious than Jewels the
heart of her husband trusts in her and
he will have no lack of gain
she does him good and not harm all the
days of her life
Proverbs 15 32.
whoever ignores instruction
despises himself
but he who listens to reproof gains
intelligence
the fear of the Lord is instruction in
wisdom and humility comes before honor
Proverbs 13 verse 20.
whoever walks with the wise becomes wise
but the companion of fools will suffer
harm the disaster pursues sinners
but the righteous are rewarded with good
Proverbs 12 verse 1.
whoever loves discipline loves knowledge
but he who hates reproof is stupid
a good man obtains favor from the Lord
but a man of evil devices
he condemns
no one is established by wickedness
but the root of the righteous will never
be moved
proverbs 31 verse 8.
open your mouth for the mute
for the rights of all who are destitute
open your mouth judge righteously
defend the rights of the poor and needy
Proverbs 22 24.
make no friendship with a man given to
anger
nor go with a wrathful man lest you
learn his ways and entangle yourself in
a snare
Proverbs 13 verse 11.
wealth gained hastily
will dwindle
but whoever gathers little by little
will increase it
Proverbs 3 verse 9.
honor the Lord with your wealth and with
the first fruits of all your produce
then your barns will be filled with
plenty
and your Vats will be bursting with wine
Proverbs 19 verse 2.
desire without knowledge is not good and
whoever makes haste with his feet misses
his way
when a man's Folly brings his way to
ruin
his heart rages against the Lord
Proverbs 22 verse 26.
be not one of those who give pledges who
put up security for debts
if you have nothing with which to pay
why should your bed be taken from under
you
Proverbs 23 verse 22.
listen to your father who gave you life
and do not despise your mother when she
is old
by truth and do not sell it by wisdom
instruction and understanding
the father of the righteous will greatly
Rejoice he who fathers a wise son will
be glad in him
let your father and mother be glad let
her Who Bore you rejoice
Proverbs 19 verse 20.
listen to advice and accept instruction
that you may gain wisdom in the future
many are the plans in the mind of a man
but it is the purpose of the Lord that
will stand
Proverbs 23 verse 19.
here my son and be wise
and erect your heart in the way
be not among drunkards
where among gluttonous Eaters of meat
for the drunkard and the Glutton will
come to poverty and Slumber will clothe
them with rags
Proverbs 21 verse 13.
whoever closes his ear to the Cry of the
poor will himself call out and not be
answered
Proverbs 23 verse 9.
do not speak in the hearing of a fool
for he will despise the good sense of
your words
Proverbs 21 verse 19.
it is better to live in a desert land
than with a quarrelsome and fretful
woman
Proverbs 29 verse 9.
if a wise man has an argument with a
fool the fool only rages and laughs and
there is no quiet
bloodthirsty men hate one who is
blameless
and seek the life of the upright
a fool gives full vent to his Spirit but
a wise man quietly holds it back
Proverbs 22 15.
Folly is bound up in the heart of a
child
by the rod of discipline drives it far
from him
Proverbs 20 verse 1.
wine is a mocker strong drink a brawler
and whoever is Led astray by it is not
wise
Proverbs 5 verse 1.
my son be attentive to my wisdom incline
your ear to my understanding that you
may keep discretion
and your lips May guard knowledge
for the lips of a forbidden woman drip
honey and Her speech is smoother than
oil
but in the end she is better as wormwood
sharp as a two-edged sword
her feet go down to death
her steps follow the path to sheol
she does not Ponder the path of life
her ways wander and she does not know it
Proverbs 16 verse 1.
the plans of the heart belong to man but
the answer of the tongue is from the
Lord all the ways of a man are pure in
his own eyes but the Lord weighs this
birth
commit your work to the Lord
and your plans will be established